one of the things that i thought was
fascinating that you looked at was uh
kissing the use of human kissing what's
what's the explanation for that
uh
it it's one of those things again for
which there is never been really a
satisfactory explanation
one of the interesting things about
kissing though is in mouth to mouth
kissing i mean not all cultures do it so
it doesn't necessarily work
everywhere but it it seems that pretty
much it's as close to universal as
anything uh might be in the you know
large numbers of cultures actually do it
the key to it
is you're exchanging information
on your essentially your immune system
so it it's reckoned a a five-minute kiss
results in the
transmission from one person to the
other of tens of billions of
um
chemicals and uh
you know sort of bacteria and all sorts
of other things that belong to your
insides
um to the other person and it's giving
them a very direct measure
of the quality of your immune system so
if you think about
falling in love
courtship in other words as a process of
assessment so it starts since you enter
the room and your eyes lock across the
room and you go oh that's a very
attractive one that
phil's ticks all those kind of physical
attraction boxes i i shall go and
explore further and you
go closer and
engage in conversation and uh so then
you're picking up all sorts of cues
about their
back cultural background if you like
them how they think and psychological
background and in the conversation and
then if you're still if you're still
happy
at that point you kind of go through a
point of reappraisal do i like what i
see or do i pull out now
when i i still can or do i go to the
next level you go to the next level it's
a bit more sort of physical so you you
you have a grapple and a dance
um and at this point you can you can get
a good sniff
of the other person uh smell uh what
they're saying nothing important in
humans very important very important
because again the same genes that
determine your smell
are the ones that determine your
um immune system
right and what you're looking for
is somebody who has the different immune
system
it seems that what what you're looking
for is somebody who
kind of looks like you in all sorts of
ways so it's keeping a good bunch of
genes together from your
extended family if you like
this is what's known as optimal
inbreeding or optimal out breeding you
know
you know why would you waste the fact
that
history of mating in your ancestors
produced this perfect
person
that is you
why would you waste all that
by dispersing it by marrying uh or
mating with people who
are
not so perfect as you right so the
answer is
you look for people who is similar to
you
facially and all these kind of things
look like you as much as possible
because that's indicative of the fact
that you
probably have common ancestry
and of course in village societies that
would work really well and it probably
doesn't work so well for us because we
don't actually meet people that really
look like us very often these days but
in village society you know you can tell
tell it our village from that village
they just look different
um
uh uh
and that's not just how they comb their
hair
physically did i see that you said that
men can actually smell when women are
ovulating yes yes
um so so this this is the point that
well we can come back to ourselves just
finish the the
make choice bit is that
the one thing you aren't looking for
somebody to be similar to you is in the
immune system because what you want
is your child to have as diverse as an
immune system as possible you did then
narrow it it is so inbreeding is bad for
all sorts of reasons but one of them is
you end up with no variability in their
immune system to resist diseases when
you say immune system what do you mean
it the body's natural immune system this
is what produces all the white blood
cells and stuff that sort of attack and
cannibalize okay and genetic viruses
genetically people have a predisposition
to be what robust against certain types
of uh
viruses and bacteria but maybe not all
of them so the goal is to kind of spread
the risk across yes okay okay yes or
it's it's
not necessarily particular resistance
particular but bacteria or what have you
but
a very strong immune system which is
because the immune system is very
adaptive
to what's thrown at it right it learns
uh to recognize
uh foreign bodies that have invaded you
and this isn't just genetic this is
something which is going to be
influenced by if you were an adventurer
if you'd been away
of the immune system itself this
capacity
for the essentially the white blood
cells uh to
identify the natural killer cells the nk
cells uh to identify foreign bodies in
your system and seek and destroy as it
were
and uh you know what you i mean there
will be an element probably from
different exposures
in terms of lineages
uh
that have you know sort of produced some
genetic adaptation to particular kinds
of viruses maybe but the essence of it
is you want
as much diversity as you can get there
and that
smelling somebody
is
as the sort of semi-distance cue
is the best way to find that out and and
you know the famous cases are eskimos
and maori's rubbing noses and we all
think they're rubbing noses they're not
what they do is they put their noses
side by side and they sniff
and take in a deep breath
and it's called uh i forget the term uh
use
how it's translated but essentially it's
breathing in the spirit is that the
equivalent of the european air kiss on
both eggs yes exactly the same thing
and this is why people pick babies up
and sniff them if you've ever watched
newborn babies when they're being sort
of passed around
everybody goes
holds them up to a big whiff of the baby
and pretends not to be sniffing but they
sniff there is a question about it
so um and you know we get a lot of cues
from
uh much more cues from smell than we
really
like to think and we're actually quite
good i mean mothers can tell
uh their offspring from other people's
offspring by their smell alone
um
the the the the big issue uh um really
in this context is perfume right perfume
billions of dollars are spent every year
on perfume billions of dollars and
everybody thinks
it's to cover up your natural bad odors
and it's not
you what you're doing is you buy perfume
that exaggerates your natural your
personal natural odors that's why there
are so many different perfumes it was
just covering it up we just have one
perfume and everybody
you know
like old spice aftershave
just gets loaded
no not not not with women uh it's very
carefully chosen
to
and that this is kind of how they build
up these perfumes is you know that they
kind of match
uh different
smell characteristics as it were their
sniffers extremely good at
decomposing the smells in different
perfect mixes
um
the people that do it for them
um but
what it's doing is actually exaggerating
your natural smell of course it helps to
cover up some of the bits you don't want
to
to to to smell of but but it it's
actually
you know really part and parcel of the
and that you know courtship strategy and
that's why it's
been you know since time immemorial um
women in particular have done that
or used it
not to say that men also don't but it's
much much more important uh in in case
women but your final so you've had a
good sniff
while you're sort of
grabbing the girl in a waltz or
something like that or pretending to
dance very close
in the club
um but the final uh point really is
comes with kissing because that actually
is direct
uh experience of of um in saliva saliva
is just full
of uh um you know sort of
immune system stuff as well as digestive
stuff so it's it gives you a really
clear
it was the best you could do but that's
your final because that's invasive
that's obviously the final step in it so
courtship is like this series of steps
starting way out with distance cues
which are largely visual getting closer
and closer and closer into
literally into taste at the end what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
you